everyone my name is Damian and my
background is in machine learning and
Robotics so yes I used to work
by Machine learning to physical robots
also used to work here in Berlin
gigafactory um Tesla
and for the majority of my professional
work I was running neural networks on
gpus
and I'm just curious how many of you do
not get to run neural networks on gpus
like on a daily basis just raise your
hand if you do not get to do this
so look very few people and out of you
who do who could do it um do you like
The Experience just like give you a
thumbs up or thumbs down if you like
working yeah right I can I can relate so
you know your your Cuda problems your
memory errors the problem of
synchronization between different
machines
I feel you
um so um right now I'm working for you
know Magic
um and my goal is to solve this problem
so we built a product that aims to make
inference on CPUs a viable alternative
to gpus or even better
so this means basically you know this
seemingly goes against the Paradigm of
the current machine learning
um scope right but um I can tell you
that right now you can run you know
large NLP models or big cnns directly on
your commodity um software so CPUs
without the need of renting a GPU or you
know cluster of gpus so my goal today is
to tell you how it is done and how you
can benefit from it in my talk I'll
focus on the enabler of this technology
which is sparsity of neural networks and
as a you know I'll also talk a lot about
llms because they can also sparsified
actually it makes sense a lot to
sparsify them
um and you know they are interesting
they're the closest thing we have to AGI
right now
but before I start I just want to give
you a quick peek behind the neural magic
curtain so we just released our latest
benchmarking results from ml perv 3.0
organized by ml common so ammo Commons
is a neutral third-party Consortium
basically that provides a forum for
large star for small startups as well as
big organizations to basically Benchmark
across specific parameters in a fair
manner
and um emul Perth is basically The
Benchmark to measure performance and
power efficiency of running inference
um so the submissions came from neural
magic as well as the likes of Nvidia
Intel Lenovo Azure and this year was all
about bird because bird can be thought
about you know as an early proxy of llms
even though it's three times of
magnitude three orders of magnitude
smaller than um gpt3 for example so um
I'm I'm proud to announce that this year
we improved our numbers by the factor of
six so we can run
um Bird 1000 times faster than the
typical CPU runtime
and we're also an order of magnitude
faster than 2a2 gpus and T4 GPU so this
is pretty significant we're very proud
of that
so the agenda for today first I'll talk
about llm optimization right so LMS
stands for large language models I'll
present the current LM landscape I'll
talk about why the inference of LMS is
hard and then I'll tell you know how we
can possibly make inference more easier
more efficient
um armed with this knowledge I'll be
able to you know talk to you about how
we can change the current Computing
Paradigm for ML and finally I'll talk
about the software delivered AI
um so it's pretty funny because I was
today
um having a breakfast in Prince Albert
and I just overheard them two teenagers
talking about how chat GPT should be
banned in Germany as it is in Italy I
think and you know every time I'm here
those like spontaneous in the wild
conversations about GPT I'm pretty you
know stunned um because just two years
ago we're super happy just to fine-tune
Bird model to solve a single task for us
like sentence sentiment analysis and
right now you know they have captured
our imagination right so um
um they basically became those like
Universal General language processors
but even though GPT had crossed 1
million users in the first five days of
its sub release I think that this is not
a technology free from problems it's
definitely not a scalable one why not
well because to make the model better
you have to make it bigger and larger so
we've seen this first with gpt2 one
building parameters we felt it a lot
until we got to 100 billion and right
now we are past half a trillion
parameters right so effectively
um those networks are almost impossible
to recreate so train from scratch and
they're also very difficult to run on a
um easily accessible devices so for
example just to run the Bloom model you
would need eight a100 gpus each of them
costs around 10 15 000 Euros and to run
larger models like Palm well you know
the answer is obvious it's it's
difficult
um and it seems that we are training
even towards larger models right
um so I think that it's really important
you know to stop throwing more compute
at the algorithms and think about how to
make them more efficient
this is important for several reasons
you know first of all fashion neural
networks can reduce the costs of the
hardware required to run them making
them more accessible to researchers and
Developers
this would make us a lot less dependent
on external apis it would Foster you
know open source and democratize machine
learning and finally we could run models
on smaller devices consume less energy
and last but not least reduce the
environmental impact of this technology
and we already see that there is a
change of mind change of mindset in the
Academia for example with the recent
papers llama and chinchilla we have seen
that the researchers they stop throwing
more compute at the algorithms but they
fixed their computational budget and
they think how can we be more smart
about the algorithms and there are
various methods that have been developed
that try to make models more efficient
and I'll talk about them in my
presentation
and who of you knows hard Maru
yeah so hard Mario um used to work for
Google brain right now he has some
managerial position and stability AI
um great guy to follow I definitely can
recommend this and you know I'm happy to
see that he shares my sentiment
um so yeah ylm and friends is hard
first problem is the low paralyzability
of LMS so the inference consists of two
things basically the first one is
processing the context right so if you
want to predict a word not you have to
first process the tokens recite the
first law a robot May right and
processing the context can be done
smartly we can paralyze that but we
cannot paralyze the sampling of a new
token why because those models are Auto
aggressive which means that the
computation of each observation in the
time series relies on the previous
observation so as a result the
computations cannot be done in parallel
because the output of each of each
computation depends on the output of the
previous computation
next one is large memory footprint one
of the culprits is um attention module
in Transformers right so what happens in
this module is basically we compute
attention scores between each and every
token and you can view it as a matrix
which every entry is one attention score
or you can view it as a you know um as a
fully connected graph where each Edge is
a token sorry each node is a token each
Edge is a tension score either way
whichever you know mental model you
apply basically
um when your sentence has a length of n
you need to compute roughly N squared
attention scores for this sentence so as
we increase the context length we need
quadratically more compute and memory
another problem with the memory is the
fact that we have to store both model
parameters and the state
in memory at inference so model
parameters those are weights but what's
the state so by state I mean the past
context that you need to generate new
token right so usually the past context
is being stored as a set of pre-computed
tensors which we call KV cache so key
value cache
and it can be quickly fetched when
required during the forward pass so when
we do self-attention
um so that we avoid processing the
context redundantly at every inference
pass right so with those pre-computed KV
values we can save a bit of computation
at the cost of some storage
but when we increase the size of the
model and especially when we increase
the context length
um the KV Cache can become unbearably
big and memory intensive so for the
batch size of 512 and the context length
of 2048 your KV Cache can take up to
three terabytes which is three times
four times the size of model itself
okay so how can we you know work with
this problem so in general when we think
about model inference with the model
inference optimization we think about
two things the first one is you want to
reduce the memory footprint of the model
and the other one we want to reduce
number of flops so numbers the desired
computation
and there are several methods that can
make our models cheaper in memory and or
faster in time and I want to focus on
those techniques which are model
agnostic so you can apply them to LMS
but you can also apply them to MLPs cnns
whichever architecture
and those are pruning knowledge
distillation and quantization and
together I like to call them compound
sparsity
so pruning first so pruning is a family
of methods that remove parameters from
neural networks while maintaining the
original accuracy right so the goal is
here to make Network to keep the network
as good as before but reduce
computational costs to run them so in
the context of sparsity we very often
talk about two representations the dense
representation which is the network as
we know them with fully unpruned days
dense weight matrices and there is also
sparse representation whereas you can
see some of the connections some of the
neurons are being turned off
so how to obtain this representation you
can either do the so-called sparse
training or post-training pruning so
sparse training means that at the same
time you optimize your models and you
try to choose those weights which will
not be likely very important at the end
for the model so you try to remove them
while you're training post training
pruning means that you basically take
your dense pre-trained model and then
you apply some kind of Criterion to find
the least interesting least important
weights for example you can just take a
look at the magnitude of those weights
in the easiest case and you remove them
so you try basically to remove those
weights which are at least
um
um important for the for the model
um and neural magic has this great um
repository for sparse and sparse
quantized models so you can just go them
go there and you can take a look at the
print models which we have in there you
can download them you can play with them
and I took two examples from sparzoo
which is computer vision model resnet
and NLP model bird base
and what I want to basically show you is
that you can prune those models up to 95
90 so you keep just you know five
percent of your model size
you're accuracy does not go down in any
meaningful way compared to the dense
um Baseline accuracy but you can you
know you can achieve 3x 4X speed up
compared to the Baseline and you can
reduce the size of your model even by an
order of magnitude almost so my goal
here is to show you that pruning is not
just you know a a toy method which is
used in Academia it can really deliver
Great Value to customers right now
um but you know resnet 50
a couple like you know tens of million
parameters bird base
of over 100
million parameters but llms they do not
have millions of parameters they have
billions of parameters right so it'll be
really great if we could sparsify those
models why because if I told you for
example the GPT 175 model to run it you
need eight a100 gpus so either you know
pay right now about 80 000 Euros to run
it or you need to rent gpus it's going
to cost you about 200 300 Euros per day
rough estimates
so this is where Spar CPT comes in so um
it's some research from IST Austria in
collaboration with neural Magic
and to my best knowledge is the first
post training printing method which
targets large gpt-like models so think
about hundreds of billion parameter
models which are the next token
predictors
um
so let's take a look at this diagram so
the green line
um is the the other results
um the y-axis is perplexity which is
like degradation of the model and on the
x-axis we can see sparsity so as we
increase sparsity we can see that
perplexity does not go up until we hit
the point of 50 60 only then the
perplexity the degradation comes up so
this means that you can remove up to 50
60 of the network slates and you did not
pay any price for that right which is
pretty great because if you think about
this it's 100 billion parameters which
you can just remove
um so you know just think about you know
what does it say about how inefficient
we are with those networks and how over
parameterized they are
and I would love to go into more details
on this research but I will not have
time so you can either talk to me after
the presentation I will be I would love
to talk about it or you can just scan
the QR code it's going to send you to
the neural magic blog which talks about
this method
so in the meanwhile I'll drink some
water
um cool all right
um so next one is knowledge installation
so this is a very um
I wouldn't say simple but
straightforward method so imagine that
you have your model which is very good
but very big and you have to deploy it
in some constrained environment
so obviously you are not able to do it
right so what you can do is you can take
a smaller version of this model
perhaps trying to train it on the same
data set
and then hope is going to work fine but
very often it doesn't right because it
doesn't have the same capacity to learn
the same presentation as the big model
but the big model already has this
representation inside its weights right
it already has a very good compressed
representation of the data set so why
not in some way transfer this knowledge
to the smaller model and this is
basically you know this idea of
distillation so for example
um
um imagine you have a classification
problem so you would train your student
basically to try to mimic the output
space of the teacher right so for
classification problem you would give
both teacher and student the same image
student the teacher will output some
um
distribution over class labels and you
would try the teacher to make it mimic
the same distribution right this is the
idea
and now I would say the most popular at
least in my view example of legislation
was the silbert so very short paper
um very readable and the gist is that
basically the authors took Bert big
model created a smaller version which is
the stillbird
um 40 40 smaller and thus 60 faster
and they were able to distill the
knowledge from bird to the stillbird so
that the still bird maintains 97
97 percent of teachers capabilities
right so second row are the results for
Bay for for Bay bird base the third row
is the silver the first score is the
compound score on all of those tasks and
then you have single um scores for you
know every task which Encompass you know
text classification question answering
and whatnot
and another very recent success story
was alpaca
so um this was a you know do-it-yourself
attempt to recreate chat GPT by the um
students of Stanford and their goal was
to do it cheaply on the shoestring
budget so they paid um 600 dollars to do
that
um and also they were able to run the
resulting model on a single GPU so how
did they do it well if you would like
you know to recreate such a GPT good
luck
um but what you would have to do is you
would have to first train a very big llm
with a very general understanding of
them of them of language and then you
would fine tune it on your data set of
instructions
so the students you know first they took
a llama model from Facebook which is a
pretty good state of the art um like a
general llm and then they had to somehow
you know find the data set of
instructions usually to get this data
set you would have to pay a lot of money
but the idea was why not just fetch it
from chat GPT so they wrote down 200
example tasks and the sgpt hey take a
look at those examples can you generate
more of those and charge GPT did
generate 52 000 of those similar
um you know like similar instructions
actually very nice distribution of those
tasks as the authors have shown their
blog post
and then the the students fine-tuned
llama on those on this data set from GPT
and thus alpaca was born and the
author's payment has similar
capabilities as chargpt
but what's really interesting you know
once again you have this notion of
pulling the knowledge from the big model
into a smaller compressed model
and finally quantization so quantization
is a you know it's a family of
techniques for running models with lower
Precision data so probably many of you
still runs neural networks where the
weights are encoded as 32-bit
numbers
and very often you that you do not need
this accuracy even worse the accuracy
you know causes those those models to be
very big take a lot of disk space so for
example resident 50 has 26 million
weights and 16 million activations if
you were to
um
if you were to save this model in 32-bit
representation well it takes about 170
megabytes of your disk space
but we have already seen that you know
32 bits maybe too much we can very often
get away with 16 bits or sometimes even
with 8 Bits so if you were to represent
a resident 50 with 8 Bits it would take
you know four times less
disk space
important if you want to run for example
resident 50 on a microcontroller and
also your memory bandwidth would go down
by the factor of 4 which is no
how much time it takes for you to like
move tensors
um pretty pretty significant
but quantizing LM is not trivial so that
works at all
um they've shown that inside Transformer
they're hidden States tend to contain
outlier features right so basically
because of this peculiar Transformer
architecture
the the the the
matrices inside Transformer they tend to
look like this so they have very few
like I mean very few very sparse um
outlier features
but they mess up the whole quantization
so if you take this Matrix
you quantize it you multiply it by a
weight Matrix and dequantize it you're
gonna have very big quantization error
because of those sparse outliers so what
you can do you can before the matmo you
can decompose this Matrix into outlier
Matrix and non-outlier Matrix and now
the outlier get multiplied in the 16-bit
world space
while the nanopliers get quantized down
to 8-bit you perform your operation and
then you de-quantize right so
effectively the researchers they
basically first of all
um they do most of the computation in
8-bit as they wish to right because 99
of the computations will be done in
8-bit but at the same time they got rid
of this problem that outliers were
messing up their results
so 8 Bits is feasible on Transformers
can we go lower
yes we can so um gptq once again
research from our friends IST Austria
very similar to sparse GPT is that it's
just that right now we want to get
quantized weight matrices and not pruned
weight matrices
um so take a look at the diagram y-axis
once again perplexity x-axis right now
size of the model right our Baseline is
the sp16
um results I think it's a it looked like
a great line to me before but you know
this is the the line the bottom line
basically
um the current state of the art is the
blue line and the research that gptq is
the red line so you can see that you can
you know reduce the Precision of the
weights
by the factor of 4 from 16 to 4 and you
still can pretty much match the Baseline
especially for the very big networks
right because the over parameterized you
can get away with more compression
um yes as I told you all those
techniques
um they can be applied together to
basically maximize the efficiency of the
model and you know I like to call those
techniques together compound sparsity
and neural magic in neuromagic we have
those open source libraries for applying
specification recipes star neural
networks also your neural networks so
you have your network you just go there
we show you how to write a recipe so you
can either you know find find tune your
network in the sparse way or you can
apply the so-called you know the post
post trending pruning or quantization
so you don't retrain but you just apply
it
um you know without additional training
yes
um so yeah I would like to summarize
this this part of the presentation once
again by the you know prediction from
hard Mario
um I definitely share his sentiment here
so right now we have seen that you can
basically compress your model
um by a large degree and you'll you know
you'll not you not suffer from that you
will not see any like very um big
degradation but your model will be
smaller and now I want to talk to you
about how neural Magic
we use this fact to basically turn the
Paradigm of computing on its head
so one of the great enablers of the AI
revolutions we see right now were gpus
right so we constantly found out and I
think Alice krusniewski was is to be um
thanked that gpus can help us to run
machine learning networks fast
so this is how we go about running
networks nowadays right so we have GPU
which has like you know thousands of
cores and also it has its
pretty limited but high bandwidth memory
so what we do is we load our model graph
into this memory we load our input into
this shared memory and we apply you know
those thousands of cores to basically
apply thousands of Terra Ops per second
compute to run the network
and we got very comfortable with this
notion that in order to make progress
we constantly maximize the throughput of
the compute
and whenever we hit the wall because of
the small memory what we do we just
cluster more gpus together right
um so we get GPU GPU clusters TPU pods
and and whatnot and to be honest in this
Paradigm this all makes sense
so for example CPUs will not work very
well in this paradigm
so once again gpus a lot of caches very
tiny is sorry a lot of a lot of course
thousands of course very tiny caches
very small memory but very high memory
bandwidth on the other hand CPUs have
few cores I mean like dozens of cores
usually very large very powerful caches
um but very poor bandwidth right to
memory
so when we run networks on gpus we try
to basically take advantage of those two
great properties of gpus right so first
of all we utilize the high bandwidth of
memory so you can quickly read and write
the tensor layers the tensors between
the layers
and also parallelism so you know your
goal is to saturate the compute of your
of your course and then you can
basically quickly in this synchronous
fashion go layer after layer to get to
your output
um so doing the same thing on CPUs so
running depthwise is a very bad idea for
two reasons first of all networks are
compute intensive and you know CPUs do
not have the proper um
the amount of you cannot do
that many flops and second problem is
the bandwidth limitation you know we
cannot move data as fast as in gpus
so how can we turn this problem on its
head well so we had two problems right
the first one is the compute the second
one is the um the bandwidth memory
bandwidth so with the compute we use
sparsity to basically compress our
networks
um a lot right so this is how we
basically achieve less compute
um so we can work with those much less
compute intensive and sparsified models
but we are still memory bound right we
still need to read and write to memory
and this is slow
so what can we do is we can just execute
networks in the caches right caches are
pretty big for CPUs
um they are very fast so for CPU to
communicate with cache it's like
nanoseconds
um so we do not run synchronously layer
by layer but we run asynchronously depth
wise so to speak so we use those tensor
column depthwise execution algorithm to
run networks faster
so that's it basically
um yes so this is basically
um how we enable the software delivered
AI so neural magic
um you you may have already heard me
talking about those two products so
first one is parsu which is our
repository was parsified models another
one is parcel which is open source
library for um specification recipes
and the last one is divspars right so
it's basically the last product which
which kind of like you know ties the the
all the rest together this is our
sparsity aware inference runtime which
allows you to run on CPUs
so it really you know it's really
important that because of the sparsity
we are able to run it fast
um yes so these bars as I mentioned fast
on CPUs we support both x86
architectures so Intel and AMD chips
also our machines so you can run on your
Lenovo lab Lenovo laptop on your MacBook
um Raspberry Pi Android avsw Gravitron
servers I also have full Enterprise
offering so we offer this as a as an
Enterprise
um so we give you full support
um if you represent the company feel
free to talk to me um you know it's
pretty it's pretty great
um
yes and there is new addition to our
product portfolio this is um sparsify so
right now we're about to launch Alpha so
if you want to
um join the the wait list please scan
the barcode this is basically a service
service platform
which is like a One-Stop shop for
specification so just to create the
state of Dr as parsified models you come
with your problem for example with
either a problem or a model or a problem
of data and data set and your targets
you want to optimize for Speed model
size through Port latency and we give
you a toolbox to solve it it's a
platform we have a very nice UI
we take you know care of of your hyper
parameter tuning we allow you to run
experiments so it's pretty cool um I
encourage you to join the waitlist
um and finally you know all of this
stuff it's a lot to digest I think I I'm
not sure that specification is that much
of a big topic right now in ml I'm
pretty sure it's going to change very
often very very soon so what we give you
is
um you know something along the lines of
HBO or Amazon Prime which is neural
flicks
um it's a it's a series of videos where
we talk about everything so we talk
about why we do what we do
um why do we do it on CPUs and we also
give you Hands-On examples on how you
can basically apply those techniques to
your own problems I especially recommend
those two videos by those handsome twin
brothers
um
yeah I guess that's it we can now go
into q a if I don't manage to answer any
question feel free to talk to me um out
there yeah
thanks
[Applause]
awesome thanks very much and so well
with the time awesome yes
cool
um I forgot to mention that we're using
slido for this talk as well but you're
also experienced by now that you you
actually put your questions in here
already thanks very much so let's start
from the top uh wasn't gpt4 already
trained with a trillion parameters
wasn't gpt4 already trained with a
trillion parameters I think we don't
know right like they never told us how
big gpt4 is but we can suspect this
there were rumors but we don't know
it seemed that perplexity actually
improved at the beginning until around
30 sparsity and only got worse Beyond 50
sparsity any ideas on why that is this
is actually pretty interesting a
phenomenon so sometimes sparsity can
improve your accuracy
and there is a pretty simple explanation
for that sparsity can act as a
regularization technique right but
this happens sometimes yes
do you need specialized runtimes to take
advantage of prune networks is o n and X
enough
um so our next runtime
um is basically what we very often you
know compare ourselves to and we are our
runtime the disperse runtime
um is you know orders are magnitude
faster and then Onyx runtime
um the cool thing which I want to
highlight is that very often the
disparse runtime is faster it's very
fast not only for prune models but also
for dense models and this happens
systematically that even if we don't
specify a model if we compare this model
right we compare the efficiency of this
model the runtime of this model In These
Bars analytics runtime we are still
faster
yeah thanks how do you measure accuracy
for LMS is the accuracy loss when
shrinking llms suffered in edge cases
that may be important to clients
ah this very depends on the llm so for
example like recently I've been thinking
with with um code gen which is an llm
which basically wrote code for you and
the way how you um measure you know the
the correctness of this of this model is
by
um basically giving it a a small um
coding problem it's it's supposed to
solve it and then solve and basically um
you you you you need to we need to look
like how many unit tests
um pass right so this already depends on
the LM sometimes it's perplexity
um
yeah so depends when it comes to metrics
and the second part of the question was
sorry I already put it into archive
um is the accuracy loss when shrinking
llm suffered in edge cases that may be
important to clients
not really sure I mean I think the
general sentiments that those LMS are
sober parameterized and they have so
many parameters that it's very hard to
see like significant drop also I don't
think that there are many clients who
use llms right now so it's hard to say
and why they not why they are not using
LMS because of the reasons that I
mentioned before yeah
so we don't have this data already
cool
you showed the memory reduction how is
the reduction in latency for the
inference
um so basically we have seen that you
know you can achieve reduction latency
with our of our runtime
um and
um
well I don't know what to mention else
if you you know latency is low if you
want to for example increase throughput
um you can just for example like add
more cores of the CPU cores
um yeah
things
can one use these techniques in the
library you showed on any Transformer
based models like the ones from hugging
face
yes so we have full integration with hug
and face and yeah especially having Face
we have very good integration so
absolutely yes you can
um if someone if someone is interested I
can I can either send you like I can
propose you to take a look at the videos
the neural Flex or talk to me I can like
show you the code directly or send you
to some demos
and I guess this is related how
difficult is it to apply these methods
on already trained pytorch TF models
stf Transformers no Transformers
um yes so anyway so we work a lot with
python right so if you come with pytorch
um you'll probably be fine
um and as I mentioned we have very good
integration for Transformers um hugging
phase Transformers so absolutely it
should be a breeze
can you combine all three methods over
the model deteriorate too much when
chaining the methods absolutely not so
basically if you do it right you can you
can apply this compounds Varsity very
well so for example I think in sparsu
one model which uses all those methods
is bird so we have bird which is
quantized pruned and also
um we also apply another translation to
it so absolutely you can you can do all
of it together and um it actually makes
a lot of sense
it says follow-up runtime question I
don't know which question is the
follow-up too sorry is there any
difference between dents and sparse
models into inference time without a
special run time yes there is so um I
would say there are two facades to it
first of all is if you want for example
to run a prune model just in pytorch
those you know those removed weights are
zeros so those zeros will still be
treated by pytorch as operations right
so we'll not see this um the speed up
um and there was a second thing I wanted
to mention
also
um sparsity is not something which is um
supported by most of the hardware out of
the box so for example Nvidia gpus they
only support
um and that in all cases structure
sparsity so I haven't talked about that
but structures sparsity well for example
we're in neural magic we take advantage
of the unstructured sparsity which is I
would say much more flexible and much
more powerful type of sparsity
um but yes right now it's not trivial to
run sparsified models you cannot just do
it out of the box in many cases but I
think it's gonna it's changing it's
changing very fast
cool accuracy loss is only two percent
on some Metric but how does it feel to
use for a human is the deterioration
noticeable
I mean of course there are some use
cases like I know with self-driving cars
right when you chase every fraction of
you know your metric but in most cases
in the long tail of of the cases we see
that our customers you know they're fine
sometimes with smaller accuracy for
example if they can really run network
fast right so that depends on your use
case but we have seen it in the real
world
um
you know it's it's just the most
important thing is that you can run and
deploy
um and if there is some of accuracy drop
which is you know it's really negligent
does steep spots run on Mac M series as
well
so I'm guessing the arm processes yes
um
I'm pretty sure it does
um but you need to because the arm
release is very recent
um so I'm not that sure I will need to
check but I'm pretty sure it should
right now or we will be able to support
it very soon
how do you decide which node runs on
which CPU do you optimize the assignment
of nodes to minimize the dependency
between cores
well this will be a question to one of
our runtime Engineers because I'm a
machine learning engineer so if you have
questions which go more in depth into
the runtime I would suggest you to go
into our slack and then there are
runtime Engineers who really know in
depth more about this architecture
all right do you have models uploaded on
hugging face
um
no so our models are in sparzu
um but you can basically also
um for example sparsify a model from
hugging face right so you can integrate
with hugging face right so what you can
do is you you like a modern hugging
phase you can basically through sparse
smell sparsify it and then run it using
um these parts this is possible
all right that's the ones from slido
anybody in the room with another
question we still have a little bit of
time sure
maybe this is something for the runtime
Engineers but I thought I'd ask anyway
which is like how how do the course
communicate like the output of why it's
like if there's like cross dependencies
yeah I don't want to talk about
something which I'm not very nice so
once again for the run time yeah okay
but that's not like a general idea
um no okay question for the runtime
people yes
sure just shoot an hour
depends on the use case so the sparse
Zoom models yes so you can so you either
find you on a zoom model
you can do this or you take your model
and you fine tune it
um well what makes sense right the first
thing I would do I would just fine tune
a sparse model because it's already you
know like sparsified if this doesn't
give you a good result
which I hope it will
um you can go further with like um
sparse fine tuning on your own model so
both pathways are valid
um it depends you know what kind of
results You're Expecting
uh how much would these sparse models
benefit from highly specialized Hardware
if five years from now there were like
everything is sparse would it make sense
for big Hardware vendors to just build
specialized compute units for them I
hope not so the whole idea of neural
magic is that you know we think that you
can there is no need for specialist
Hardware like we would like to see the
future where
you only think about machine learning as
a software and the hardware is
completely abstracted out from you right
so there is a CPU
um and you don't really care about
what's the hardware you're running on
you just run it right and CPU
um is is universal enough that you don't
have to you know create
um specialist Hardware you know I think
this is the this is the dead end which
we are getting into specialist Hardware
um it's actually you know
pretty typical of us you know people in
in in software that'll be you know when
you have a problem we first try to like
find quick and
difficult Solutions and then we at the
end we default to something which is
elegant
um and Universal
two more questions we're running out of
time so I would like to ask you to just
talk to uh Damian right afterwards yeah
just just okay afterwards okay yeah
perfect thanks very much everybody and
uh I hope we can all go back to Bitcoin
mining with our gpus very soon
have a great rest of the conference and
thanks very much again one Applause
please thank you very much